G'day.
I'm Duncan from the
Google Play Games team.
Play Games is Google's game
network for Android, iOS
and the web, with user
experiences and services
designed to enhance game play.
I'm here to tell you
about what's new,
and why it's great for you.
Three big things are
coming out-- game profiles,
quests, and saved games.
These features
could significantly
boost engagement and
retention for your game.
So listen closely to learn
how to level up your game.
Speaking of leveling
up, that reminds
me-- one of our
huge updates to Play
Games is our game profile which
now enables players to level up
across the entire
Play Games ecosystem.
They can check out
what activities
they've done to get there,
and compare themselves
against others.
This may drive significant
levels of engagement
for any game that players love.
So, leveling happens
based on points
earned from gaining achievements
in Play Games like yours.
Each game you publish
has 1,000 points
to allocate to achievements.
Why?
Because players
love to level up.
Compelling achievements
give players
a reason to engage
with your title
for longer periods of time.
You see, we've seen significant
user retention improvement
in games where high quality
achievements are available.
And the leveling system
has the same potential.
While players are checking out
their level in the Play Games
app, they can now also
compare themselves to others.
Just tap on a
face, and check out
the comparison in
the Play Games app.
Are you beating your friends?
Have you checked?
You should probably go check.
They may have just beaten you.
On top of their level, players
are now assigned a title,
based on the game
category they've
earned the most XP or
experience points in.
This means with just
a glance, players
can tell that a Level 20 Speed
Racer is a highly engaged
racing game expert, compared
to another player who
may be a Level One Rookie.
With good achievement
point allocations,
you'll set your
players on the path
to lots of fun and retention.
And while on the
path of retention,
players can engage with another
one of our new features--
quests.
With quests, you can create
time bound tasks and rewards
on top of events,
giving players a reason
to come back for
a new challenge.
Quests drive both
deeper re-engagement
and increased
retention for players.
For example, over
the last few weeks,
I've been playing the extremely,
ironically named game,
Questing Rocks.
I'd been on a quest to
earn the axe of destiny.
I fought dragons,
elves, and a rainbow
a few times, which was weird.
But it was totally worth it.
Now that I have
the axe of destiny,
I can compete in the tournament
coming up next month.
Now, normally this
kind of feature
would require a
significant live ops team
to manage regular
updates, without having
to push a new build.
That is, until now.
So how do quests work?
Let's take a seafaring
game as an example.
There are three things that
I care about in my game--
treasure found, crew
rescued, and miles sailed.
So I jump into the
developer console and define
these three events.
Next, I integrate events
that report these signals
back to Play Games.
And I also integrate the
generic quest interfaces,
so players can see my quests
as soon as I publish one.
Next, I monitor the events.
Oh, look-- people love finding
treasure, who would've thought?
So now, I go and create a quest.
But uh, hm-- Talk Like a
Pirate Day is coming up.
So I guess I'll create a
quest based around that.
It will start on
September 19, which
is International Speak
Like a Pirate Day,
and will require players to
find 50 treasures to earn
the reward of Blackbeard's
secret treasure map.
I also add some images,
including a secret treasure map
to draw a player's attention.
And then I hit publish.
So players are out
there, finding treasures,
and accepting my quests
and participating.
When a player does
find 50 treasures,
I add the secret treasure
map to their inventory.
And what do they think about it?
My community is abuzz with tales
of Blackbeard's treasure maps
and the secrets it reveals.
So many players
enjoyed the quest,
that it's time for me to go
back and look at my events
to determine what quest
I should create next.
By designing a game to send
a broad spectrum of events,
and defining quest
rewards in advance,
you can run quests
whenever you'd
like without updating your
game, to build a better
relationship with
your user community.
Players will also get to see
quests in the Play Games app
for all games they've
recently played.
This is another great
way to reengage players,
or to drive deeper engagement.
Ensure that you make your
quests easy to understand,
fun and rewarding.
Speaking of fun
and rewarding, I'd
like to introduce our
new saved games feature.
Saved games are the new
visual, cross platform,
game save for Play Games on
Android, iOS, and the web.
Saved games will mean
your players never
have to play a level
one again and allow
you to reengage your
players by reminding them
of the awesome things that
they are up to in your game.
What is unique about
saved games is the ability
to store metadata that can
improve discoverability
through the Play Games
apps and increase usability
for your players.
This metadata includes a
custom image, a description,
and a timestamp
that are presented
to players within
your own game's UI,
and within the Play Games app.
The latest saved
game for a Play will
appear on your game's detail
page in the Play Games app.
It will also appear prominently
in the home screen of the app,
reminding players why they
should come back to your game.
So let's take a closer look.
The custom image is set by you,
and should capture a screenshot
of the player's progress
in the game that
will both remind the player of
where they're at in the game,
but also entice
them to play more.
Going above and
beyond may include
overlaying other art
elements, such as your logo,
or their latest achievement,
or some particle
effects onto the game
screenshot to make
it even more compelling.
The description field should
be short, but informative,
to remind players where
they were in your game,
and why they should return.
Without it, your image
may not resonate as well.
For example, fighting
the goblin king
in the dark woods, grand master
trainer, or the deep caves,
are all a lot better
than level 12.
So to learn how to
make awesome quests,
engaging saved games,
setting achievement points
at the access code samples,
just visit our docs,
by clicking one of the
links on the screen.
Thanks for taking
the time to learn
about these awesome new
features for Play Games.
I hope you have as much fun
making great engaging quests
and compelling saved games as
we had making these features.
Cheers.